no matter who you are there will always
be moments in games where things just
don't go your way times where although
you think you've made the right play you
still manage to get punished
and in an effort to grow valorant's
still blossoming esports scene riot has
chosen to keep players on their toes by
pushing updates that tend to shake up
the meta oftentimes to ill effect
what is this gun what the [ __ ] is this
wait this this has to be hot fixed now
some players manage to breeze through
the nonsense by shifting the blame to
those around them often with good reason
riot
i ask you calmly professionally
please do something about your [ __ ]
ranked matchmaking system these guys are
actual bots they don't come they bait
they don't know what the [ __ ] they're
doing please do something about it while
others let their annoyances eat away at
them
until they just can't take it anymore
this game is just in constant mental
torture just beating you down with a
stick over and over and over and over
and over again you just lie there and
you just can take it i would love to
play more ranked valor and i would love
to lose some more elo holy this game's
so fun yes riot please take my money but
not all players share this same
sentiment some remain cool calm and
collected because
they know that molding
will only make things worse
and in valoran's brief history
one man has managed to find a way to
tame the entire community of rage filled
freaks with two simple words
all good
meet pujon fns meta envy's big brained
battle-hardened in-game leader an
esports competitor for over a decade who
has managed to crack the code when it
comes to avoiding tilt you see after
experiencing just about everything there
is to experience in the gaming world fns
now more than ever understands exactly
what it takes to outsmart his opponents
and maintain sanity when things don't go
his way but how did he develop this
elementary adage and
why is it that the entire attack fps
community decided to start living by it
all good
i deserve that one huh
all good
okay so before we dive into things i
must humbly request that you like the
video subscribe to the channel
turn on notifications
if you don't all good
now at nearly 30 years old fns is what
the esports world would call a boomer
hell he's likely been competing for
longer than some of you little tykes
have been alive but where exactly did
his competitive gaming journey begin
born in tanzania fns moved to toronto at
a young age alongside his parents and
two siblings and like many others
featured on this channel he was first
introduced to gaming by his older
brother who showed him games like fifa
and nba live
eventually fns made the jump from
console to pc
and it was then that some of his friends
introduced him to
counter-strike
the thing is his initial foray into tack
fpss
actually presented some challenges at
that point i was so not used to the pc
like i didn't play any games on the pc
specifically with my mouse and my
keyboard being used at the same time so
i just couldn't use my mouse and my
keyboard together like that's that's how
bad i was at pc at first so that was
definitely a learning curve but i fell
in love with counter-strike fell in love
with the idea of fps and not necessarily
the tactical side of it yet but just
more play against real people instead of
npcs that just blew me away entirely and
i got addicted to it with the release of
cs go in august of 2012 fns began taking
competition more seriously and joined
various up-and-coming amateur rosters
before earning his first professional
contract with counter logic gaming at
the start of 2015. clg was one of the
first top north american rosters and
living in a gaming house with his
friends and traveling to events helped
fns grow especially as a leader it's
gonna be at least who finds one switches
from burst to
single fire and he's gonna be able to
spin around and find a second one but
epines in the back of the site he's got
to go for a reload he's gonna be able to
take down one takes down another one
he's got one more to beat and that's the
trinity gets it done on the back of a
triple finesse going huge while clg did
find some success at the domestic level
the results weren't exactly coming on
the international stage so in early 2016
fns left clg to join a team solomid now
on tsm he was once again made in-game
leader but this time around he was
playing alongside some exciting young
prospects in the nac and it was his job
to foster their talents under fns's
command tsm established themselves as
one of the best teams in the region and
later that summer found themselves
competing against some of the world's
best
it's up to the device to try and get
this first frag but he goes down to
three hp here the ct's realized it as
well there is a refract but there it is
tsm in the opening game of group b
actually take down the titans in form of
astralis what's a result that is for
them of course same position he was in
last time they are locking the deagle oh
look at the xp
hits the headshot look how calm
collected and cool he looks it's tsm
moving on
despite their moderate success tsm
decided to replace fns with sean guerras
in late 2016 leaving him without a team
but with clg entering a rebuilding phase
they welcomed their old leader back with
open arms unfortunately fns's return
didn't exactly go as planned the team's
failure to qualify for two consecutive
majors and esl pro league caused clg to
pull the plug on their entire male cs go
operation he briefly joined complexity
in january of 2018 but when cloud9 lost
stewie to sk fns was given his greatest
opportunity yet with the remains of a
major winning roster this was his chance
to really put his name on the map as one
of na's premier igls but his time on c9
didn't exactly go as he hoped
oh my god fns is gonna be going down and
now skadoodle one versus three gambit
one kill away from making the
semi-finals and it's gonna be dozier
spread it's open and there's flames
everywhere he's just gonna run through
it and i don't even blame him that's it
cloud9 will be eliminated here all on
fns01 versus four he's not even gonna
get the chance somebody four kills
there's the celebration ty lue have done
it over the next couple of years fns
found himself hopping around various
tier two and a rosters but it wasn't
until he formed orglis a team with some
of his friends that he started to find
some success again sniper's on the
pillar waiting for you though it's kind
of embarrassing last two players now
moving into the b bomb site pretty close
what do i know they're able to jiggle
and flick very very nice and bentley
gets taken out as well
some shooting practices to get right in
the middle but they'll take him down
ending top of the scoreboard at 19 kills
so yeah they got
got really just monstrously spanked in
their map okay with another good kill
ten seconds for a one versus three it'll
be 19 to 17 as auglers eventually get
that win on overpass it took a lot
that's a really really good win for
douglas on that but
right as things were looking up for fns
they suddenly went to [ __ ] the covet 19
pandemic hit north american orgs started
funneling out of counter-strike and a
few of his teammates decided to jump
ship to valorant riot's new tax shooter
was starting to pick up steam and its
future as an esport looked promising but
fns was conflicted about making the move
counter-strike was my baby since i was
like 22 years of age even younger than
that actually so cs was basically my
entire life so being able to switch out
of it was difficult for me but as soon
as i switched to valorent i there were
no regrets i didn't like look back and
say like why did i do it
um only good things have come from that
with his cs teammates already headlining
other rosters fns was forced to once
again create his own team and thanks to
his reputation as a leader and his years
of competitive experience he didn't
exactly have to look too far to find
players who were willing to learn the
game alongside him fns's ragtag crew
entered the valoran scene a bit later
than most rosters but it didn't take
long for them to get their name out
there because it was a little
questionable trying to win versus
together we are terrific we've shortened
that together terrific
so it'll actually fit our graphic yes
[Laughter]
so as other rosters were picked up
around them together we are terrific
waited for their chance to represent a
tier one orc but it was around this time
that some members of the valorant
competitive community found themselves
under investigation for some
fairly
suspicious
doings
implicated among the cs go match fixing
allegations was fns's teammate calypso
who was put on blast by some of the
scene's biggest players but fns quickly
came to his teammates defense it was
merely two words
all good
and thus a meme was born almost
immediately the community latched onto
it and the two words became for fns a
catchphrase of sorts it was almost as if
the two words had completely absolved
his teammate of any potential wrongdoing
all good even became a coping mechanism
for players who found themselves in some
let's say
unfortunate situations
this looks too sweaty
all again all right i'm gonna go tower
all good i'm gonna play this round i
mean there's a cam on me and i'm smoked
this guy's sitting here
i have no idea why it caught on
but from where it came from it literally
is just something i say
as a joke
sarcastically when something absurd is
said
um like in teamspeak or something like
that or in real life uh when someone
does something that i feel like was a
little ridiculous and i don't want to
insult them i was just like all good you
know what i mean there are so many
stupid rounds that happen in valor and
some of the most unlosable rounds you
can just lose them in valor and so like
having that all good mentality is super
good it's like strong it's a good
mentality to have i mean that's always
where i live but like
you never you never like to regret
things you just want to move forward so
all good
while his catchphrase took the community
by storm fns and his teammates were
picked up by envy off the back of their
impressive performances in the valorant
ignition series the team operated like a
well-oiled machine and a lot of that was
thanks to fns's ability to see the game
in a way that not many others could
immediately i got a good feel of how to
call in the game and that's when i kind
of fell in love with ballarat was i
enjoyed
being able to out call
with this many variables
um that made that like was a huge rush
for me personally and it was like a huge
boost in motivation because i was
playing against players that started and
switched before me we were doing well in
these tournaments you know uh we'd get
like fourth third eventually second and
then eventually first
envy try to go for this push towards b
they've actually managed to make it up
towards spawn but fns who's kind of
hanging that back
that is just to get a couple of kills
and you can see them changing their plan
out of that they want to go back towards
a but they're going to take their time
to get there as they have to run all the
way back up catwalk that does allow
relics to get into a better and more
advantageous position
look at where fns is relics has no idea
fns with his big brain 30 seconds left
just
getting the best of cloud nine the
team's performances throughout the valor
and ignition series made them a hot
commodity and it wasn't long before envy
swooped them up with an org backing them
fns and his team continued to impress
they bolstered their roster with the
addition of victor crashes and mummy
before qualifying for first strike as
the number one seed astronaut pops
result as well figures what can i do
this is a bit of an odd oath coming out
from crashes but it doesn't matter in
the end caboose will get that third and
final kill
at this point envy was overflowing with
talent but their opponents were pretty
quick to throw the praise to fns
it was pretty clear that his years of
experience and counter-strike had really
set him up for success in valorance i
think envy's got in my opinion the best
in-game leader in north american history
which is fns
so when you combine young talent new
talent and mummy
um with
you know one of the best igls
na has ever had then you're gonna have a
really good team he's the igl that i
hate playing against the most because i
feel like he always has the read on like
what we're trying to do and he's always
good at making those mini micro
adjustments mid game i feel like every
single time i watch envy their calls are
always like so good they usually have
the advantage in the rounds i think envy
has like strategically and like all
their setups and stuff i love watching
envy but once first strike got underway
things didn't exactly go as planned they
managed to beat immortals in the opening
round but fell short to tsm in the
semi-finals and this marked the
beginning of a bit of a shaky run from
envy as the valorant champions tour got
underway in early 2021 they found
themselves fighting amongst the top
teams but often falling at the final
hurdle push here now the fracks come in
for the defense still two players remain
down to fns with 11 hp as asuna wraps
around
still now the 1v1 eco right through the
smoke shots come through the spike of
sticky he's got to run over he's got to
defuse he's got to find the time holding
it down on b site could it be the
thrifty victory that pushes him over the
edge as mommy tries to trade sing back
with just the classic aaron finds
another he's got the classic in hand he
can't find four but the bucky is there
now finesse has to go huge they had the
rifles but it doesn't matter except win
the rematch fns knew that a change
needed to be made they added marv to
their roster which meant that they had
the controller role covered but most of
the top teams in the region had starred
jet players who were willing to frag out
with an operator so if envy were going
to compete with the best and qualify for
masters berlin they'd need somebody who
was comfortable playing that role
thankfully
fns
knew
just the guy after failing to qualify
with andbox fns brought to the squad his
friend and former teammate
yay or as many of you know him el diablo
yay made an immediate impact helping
envy qualify for berlin as the third
seed out of n a and once fns and his
team arrived in berlin they popped off
yeah he's in a clutch spot here he does
have
one bullet left with the option that's
that blades from online if he's able to
get that all right he's good for one
it's going to be on to steal
he has to creep his way forward a red
bull clutch from yay
looking to go toe-to-toe seals in good
spot steals a good spot but no way again
oh
[Music]
way ahead of it eats the flashlight so
does victor now there's problems one
left one right what can convict to do in
this they're bounding around
victor
are you kidding me envy made their way
to the grand final without dropping a
single map and although they ended up
coming short in the end the whole team
showed up their second place finish
helped secure them a spot at valoran's
biggest event to date
champions we're a team that's very
versatile in my opinion
um i didn't think i didn't know if that
would translate onto lan because we have
a lot of inexperience on the roster as
well we haven't had that many players
that have attended a lot of lands to be
able to see like jimmy at his first land
and crashes austin was playing insane
like all my players were playing really
well and they had don't even have that
much experience
but they felt so calm to play with you
know nobody was panicking or anything
like that and like i said the confidence
we had in berlin it's gonna help me
personally as an in-game leader so much
knowing that my players are capable of
that despite their confidence heading
into champions things
quickly went south
first victor tested positive for kovid
and was forced to isolate from the rest
of the team then a loss to ascend in the
second round set them up for a rematch
against thailand's x10 crit and with
their tournament lives on the line they
fell short this gets scary very quickly
because look where crashes is lurking in
the shadows of c long they're moving to
the a site cruise will try to hold on
and he gets away with three the lockdown
will do absolutely nothing in the
playoffs this done to the back side oh
they're going to eliminate sushi boy to
start with but he is still going strong
in the backside down through the cloud
first
comes the bladestorm but it's not even
needed scary closes it out and sca are
going all the way to playoffs now
although envy didn't exactly end their
season how they were hoping fns and his
squad had one hell of a year he proved
just like he always has that he's
capable of building a roster and leading
them to success he's done it for nearly
a decade now he's built teams only to
watch them crumble on the biggest stages
but somehow fns never gives up he may
still be searching for that one big win
in valorant but his desire to compete
has never been stronger and although his
mantra only took the valorante world by
storm this past year
it's a subtle reminder of just how much
adversity he's overcome where some
players might just call it quits fns
takes his losses in stride he continues
to fight and heading into the 2022 vct
season envy now optic still have their
heads held high in part because of their
extraordinary leader because with fns at
the helm
everything is truly
all good
yeah it's definitely all good right now
for sure
i want to make sure that we don't
doesn't seem like we're
[ __ ] on these players because the
theme here obviously is like when [ __ ]
happens to you in a game we started this
video by saying sometimes [ __ ] happens
like you made the right decision you're
a great player and you just get timing i
don't think i'm gonna do this but i i
did have a thought when i was reading
the script north americans started to
pull out of counter-strike like a high
schooler in the back and then just cut
myself off and cut to can be like nope
not making that joke miles would like it
but i don't know if it's i think it's
kind of in for a taste